سنبدا من هذه الصور المباشره مشاهدينا من
اسطنبول حيث يشهد محيط بلديه اسطنبول
الكبرى تظاهرات دعت اليها المعارضه رفضا
لقرار سجني رئيس بلديه المدينه المعارض
اكرم امام اوغلو ومنعه من العمل السياسي
[موسيقى]
ويقود هذا تجمع رؤساء وسده احزاب معارضه
كبيره في تركيا من ابرزهم رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ورئيسه حزب الخير القومي هو رئيس
حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم بالاضافه الى 10
رؤساء بلديات ولايات كبرى في تركيا
وما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
التظاهرات التي تحصل بمحيط بلديه اسطنبول
هذه التظاهره للاحزاب المعارضه طبعا رفضا
لقرار سجن رئيس بلديه اسطنبول هؤلاء هم
رؤساء الاحزاب المعارضه ورئيس بلديه
اسطنبول الذي حكمت المحكمه بسجنه تقريبا
سنه سنتين واكثر وبعض الاشهر وبعض الايام
ايضا
وكانوا بالامس دعوا الى تجمع في محيط همم
بلديه اسطنبول ويبدو ان هناك اعداد كبيره
قد استجابت لهذه الدعوه حيث احتسد
المعارضون الاتراك في محيط بلديه اسطنبول
للمشاركه في هذه التظاهره وهذا التجمع
للاحزاب المعرضه
قتل المريجي
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو في
كلمه له امام هذا التجمع الاحتجاجي لانصار
المعارضه قبل قليل طبعا قال ان السلطه
الحاكمه في تركيا لا تحترم القانون ولا
الاخلاق وتسعى لخنق اصوات الناخبين نتابع
ين وهي لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق كما
حاولت السلطه في تركيا تعطيل عمل بلديه
اسطنبول بعد خساره الانتخابات واريد ان
اشير الى انه تم تغيير القاضي الذي كان
موكلا بقضيته لانهم حسوا بانه لن يصدر
حكما كما يرغبون تركيا تقف على مفترق طرق
بين من يقبل بالسياده الوطنيه
من لديهم حساسيه من السياده الوطنيه
زيدان زنجلو مراسل العربيه من اسطنبول
ينضم الينا زيدان اهلا بك معنا تبعت هذه
التظاهرات ماذا يمكن ان تنقل لنا من
مشاهدات وابرز المواقف
رؤساء الاحزاب السته يعلنون انتهاء هذه
الفاعليه او هذه التظاهره الكبرى التي دعت
اليها او دعت اليها رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
بمشاركه رؤساء احزاب ابطال السداسيه وهم
قاده احزاب معارضه همم شاركوا ايضا في هذا
التجمع بالعموم كان التجمعا كبيرا شهدا
حضور الالاف من انصار اكرم امام اوغلو
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول وايضا من انصار
الاحزاب المعارضه بالعموم الجميع في
كلماتهم همم رفضوا قرار المحكمه الصادر
بحق اكرم امام اوغلو همم والقاضي بسجنه
لمده سنتين وسبعه اشهر وحضره من العمل
السياسي ايضا كان هناك ايدانا
الى طريقه عمل المحكمه وطريقه التعاطي
السلطه مع المرشحين او الفائزين في
الانتخابات الرؤساء البلديات والرؤساء
الاحزاب على مستوى الولايات همم كان هناك
ما ذكرت نقد كبير لقرار المحكمه بالعموم
يعني يمكن تلخيص همم كل ما شاهدناه هذا
اليوم بان المعارضه التركيه تريد حجد
الشارع بشكل كبير ضدها همم قرار المحكمه
وح- وحظر اكثر امام اوغلو من العمل
السياسي هذا من جانب من جانب اخر تسع ايضا
المعارضه الى المضيف الاجراءات القانونيه
للطعم بهذا القرار طبعا ميسون القرار لن
يكون نافذه قبل المصادقه عليه من محكمه
الاستئناف ومن المحكمه العليا وهذا
الموضوع بطبيعه الحال يستغرق وقت طويل لكن
بكل الاحوال المعرض المعارضه تريد استغلال
هذا القرار سواء تطبق او الغي من قبل
محكمه الاستئناف استغلال هذا القرار بحق
اكرم في الحملات الانتخابيه القادمه ولا
سيما ان الانتخابات ستكون حاسمه ومثل هذا
القرار يمكن ان يجذب همم يجذب
المزيد من الناخبين همم الغاضبين من
القرارات الحكوميه وفقا ما تراها المعارضه
لذلك هي فرصه لاحزاب المعارضه والاسيه من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكبر احزاب المعارضه
نعم في الاستثمار بهذا القرار وتبعيات هذا
القرار
تلحقه بعد هذا التجمع وهذه الدعوه له
ذه نعم كما ذكرت الان سيبدا المسار
القانوني من هذه القضيه فريق المحامين
المكلف بالدفاع عن رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
سيستانيف الحكم الصادر بحقه يوم امس لذلك
سنشد اجراءات قانونيه خلال الفتره القادمه
هذه الاجراءات لخص بالطعم بقرار المحكمه
الذي صدرها
هل هناك من دعوات لتستمر هذه التظاهرات
مثلا ام لم يتطرقوا الى ذلك
نعم حتى الان يعني بحسب ما شاهدناه لن
يكون هناك دعوه قريبه لكن لا شك ان
الدعوات ستستمر لا سيما ان حملات معارضه
مستمره في الاساس في كل الولايات وهناك
تجمعات جماهيريه في معظم الولايات التركيه
التي يذهب اليها قاده المعارضه همم طبعا
همم
الحملات الانتخابيه بدات بشكل فعلي سواء
من قبل الحزب الحاكم او من المعاظه لذلك
التجمعات الجماهيريه من كلا الطرفين
ستستمر في الشارع خلال الايام والاشهر
القادمه